OK.
Let's go next to our caller from the four
one zero area code.
Who's calling today from four one zero?
David Muna's Jim, did you say Tim or Jim?
Jim with a J.
Jim with a J. All right, what's going on,
Jim?
Thanks for taking the call.
Things stand out in your.
Well, thank you.
OK.
I just wanted to get your read on the Q and
on stuff, and I'm curious to see what percentage
you think of the right.
Is sort of this on board with some of that
stuff?
And it's you know, I've only just kind of
started to hear about Q and on stuff, and
it seems problematic.
I'm just I'm I'm curious what your readers
on how how much you might see that on the
right side of the aisle.
So I don't have any independent assessment.
But it's earlier this week I interviewed Alex
Kaplin from Media Matters and Alex said that
we're probably talking about millions, but
not tens of millions.
That's that's the current assessment that
Alex had.
And I would I would, you know, defer to him
on that.
And that seems about right.
If you look at sort of like tweet volume and
Facebook groups.
And remember, some of these movements seem
larger.
When you're looking at the Internet, but they're
really not that big.
And, you know, we saw that.
We've seen that with a lot of different movements.
I think this is what surprised a lot of people
during the Democratic primary.
How did Joe Biden get all these millions of
votes?
Well, if you just look online, the sort of
Bernie AOC left seems bigger than it actually
is.
And that's not a praise or criticism.
It's just a reality.
I think that that may make.
Q And on seem like a bigger thing than it
is, but it certainly seems to be in the millions
but short of tens of millions.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so you don't think that necessarily it
might have.
It might.
It might not have a massive impact on sort
of you won't see that sort of voter shift,
get it as much as one might think, based on
headlines and stuff in the actual vote and
in the popular vote in total.
No.
But remember that there's 20 candidates that
are KUNR unaffiliated on the ballot in November,
two of whom seem to have a real shot at winning
again, according to what Alex Kaplan told
us earlier this week.
I think if you get to Q and honors in the
House of Representatives, that's going to
start to take on a little bit of a different
picture.
Right.
Yeah.
So you would think then that most of the conservative
base is more moderate?
Or do you think it's all right?
Something that's often maybe your larger part
of the constituency or.
No, here's the thing to read.
When you have something like Q in on it, it
doesn't really help us to assess where the
Republican Party is in general, because these
are really, at least for now.
This is a relatively small group.
These are outliers.
These are sort of it's it's like a it's a
slice of trumpets and trumpets or a slice
of the Republican Party.
So I don't really think that.
Q And Nonexisting tells us much about the
broader dynamics of the Republican Party.
But you're getting to something that I think
is really important, which is whenever Trump
leaves, whether it's in January or January
of 2025, whenever that is what happens to
the Trump lists that are left over.
And how does that manifest in the Senate and
the House of Representatives in governors
mansions, state Senates, et cetera?
And that's more of an open question.
But I wouldn't make any assessments about
the Republican Party from Q and on.
Really?
Yeah.
Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
And I think, you know, just building on that,
you would say the majority of Republicans
maybe.
Ah ah ah.
More moderate or more reasonable than sort
of those fringe groups.
So that.
Well, listen, if the if the standard for the
Republican Party has become very radical over
the last 20 years.
If we're comparing that to Q and on, then.
OK, I don't I don't think the majority of
the Republican Party does not have the beliefs
of Q and on, but they have their own radical
beliefs in their own way, sometimes their
radical religious beliefs, sometimes their
radical authoritarian beliefs, sometimes they're
just really widely debunked economic ideas.
So it's not like a bailout for Republicans
that they're not all as crazy as Q and on,
if you know what I mean.
Right.
Yeah, totally.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's great.
And I think the comparison of the AOC burning
stuff seems relevant to me.
But do you do you feel that there's a similar
sort of striation of the party on our side
of the aisle as well?
Or I think the dynamics are very, very different
because some of these extreme movements, some
of these extreme movements exist on the left
where they're so extreme that they're not
even really on the spectrum of sort of like
the normal political spectrum here.
Q And on his wacky it's like this, Pete, these
pizza gaiters and that type of thing for the
most part, like the Berney AOC wing of the
Democratic Party.
They're mostly voting for Joe Biden.
They understand Biden's closer to them than
Trump.
And it makes sense to remove Trump.
That's like a normal way to interact with
the political system.
Here in Massachusetts.
We had these primaries.
Everybody I know who supported Joe Kennedy
or Alex Morse is now tweeting and posting
that like, OK, our person lost, but we're
obviously voting for Markey and Richard Neal
because they're better than the alternatives.
Most people are operating in that way.
A lot of the Q and on people are in a totally
different universe where they're not even
on the political spectrum in a normal way.
Right.
So, so.
So how then how would you compare it to.
Can you give me more sort of, I guess, clarity
on how you would compare the ANC, Bernie Sanders
type of spectrum?
You're talking about to the Q and on like,
do you think AMC and Bernie are are closer
to to the center than like the Q and owns
or or do you think?
I think it's that I just think it's the wrong
analysis.
I don't know that you get, you know, conspiracy
theorists.
It's very tough to put them on the political
spectrum.
I mean, look at anti vax as an example.
Yeah.
People that end up as anti Vax on the right
because they're skeptical of government.
And you have people that end up anti vax on
the left because they're skeptical of businesses
and they share their anti Vax sentiment.
But if you say where are they on the political
spectrum, they're both, they're all over it
and some are not on it at all.
Like they're not political other than they
are anti vax.
So I just don't think we can really analyze
it in such a sensible, rational way.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
That makes a lot of sense.
Cool.
I can't think anything of that.
Yeah, but.
All right.
I appreciate the phone call.
Yeah, of course.
Thank you.
I'm calling on David.
Great to hear from you.
We are going to go to a break and we will
take calls again very, very soon.